hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
another behind-the-scenes teaser for
Thor Ragnarok so I'm gonna play the clip
there's a whole bunch of images too so
I'm going to explain what's going on a
lot of it is just celebrating Hulk's end
of filming on the movie so here we go
it's a nice open didn't stick the
landing but I think I did yeah but just
a twisting block are we doing the air oh
you don't want to the match was close
free cost similar similar that far away
yeah so starting with the footage first
you can see he's rehearsing for a much
more acrobatic fight so you see much
more acrobatic Thor but the big news
here is this picture which makes it look
like he's going to have his guru metal
arm from the unworthy Thor comic that's
getting ready to debut so if you guys
don't know what's going on with unworthy
Thor there's a female version of Thor
during this original sin storyline Nick
Fury comes up to Thor whispers something
to his ear that makes him unworthy like
he immediately drops Mjolnir and he
can't pick it up Fury even talks to Odin
makes Odin unworthy to and we only know
that it has something to do with Angela
now that's just a comic book thing
Angela doesn't exist in the Marvel
movies I know everybody wants to see
Angela because she says you're badass
but you kind of have to work up to that
I'll explain that in a second but they
were posting a whole bunch of behind the
scenes stuff last night because it was
Mark Ruffalo you know hoax last day on
the set now that just means his last day
of principal photography they still have
post-production they'll do reshoots
later so hope will come back to set much
much later but there's like a whole
bunch of the movie that they have to
shoot that Hulk is not going to be in so
they don't need them on set anymore
so it sounds like based on the comic-con
teasers that they showed off will see
gladiator Hulk vs. gladiator Thor you
know while Loki's like cheering eating
his popcorn with the Grandmaster
watching it all go down until they break
their way out of the arena and Thor
starts to retake Asgard so I know you're
asking now does that mean
Hulk is only in like a little bit of the
movie because it sounded like he was
going to be in the entire movie so based
on the pitch I'm guessing he's in more
of the movie than say like spider-man
was in civil war like spider-man was in
about 20 minutes of civil war and if you
assume the movies going to be a little
over two hours long so we'll say for now
the Hulk is in about a quarter of the
movie you know remains to be seen
because they've only been shooting for a
couple weeks now this is really more
noteworthy for Thor's look like we're
basically saying goodbye to shampoo
model Thor in saying hello to gladiator
guerrilla Thor so if I didn't mention it
in my comic-con teaser video Thor was
done up in like Braveheart face paint so
it looks like Loki lays him low like
that's how he ends up in the arena
maybe he becomes unworthy they take his
armor from him so he gets paired down to
bare essentials like the actual Ridley
Scott gladiator film like he looks more
like Russell Crowe in that film very
simple gladiator garb like he's not
wearing elaborate armor so it's more of
a down and dirty Thor that has to claw
his way back up to the top of a scar he
doesn't have all of his toys to protect
him so like there's the possibility that
he could die if there's gonna die it is
going to be someone else from the Thor
comics to do it because not only do as
Guardians have a much more resilient
physiology like they're just naturally
stronger loki soaked a blast from the
destroyer gun with his armor on so think
about how strong they are compared to
normal humans even without their armor
on
so the real WTF felt like obviously it's
clear that they're gonna give Thor a new
look which i think is good like it's
good to mix things up eventually but the
real WTF is is will they do
unworthy Thor chop his arm off and give
him an arou metal arm so you've all
probably seen unworthy Thor since female
Thor debuted since original sin you
liked all the comics that have happened
since then he has the ARU metal arm it's
the same metal that Knoll near his
hammer is made of so he has a
super-strong arm he's super badass but
immediately after realizing that he
can't pick his hammer up in the comics
he goes to the armory in Asgard and
picks up a magical axe which is also a
room metal but the whole idea is is that
it's not as special as Mjolnir like it's
not as powerful it's still really badass
but it is not nearly as powerful as his
hammer so just to explain that I know
there are a lot of questions about
female Thor in the comics so you know
somewhat tangential to that
female Thor is actually you know spoiler
warning for female Thor if you guys
haven't read that comic so here we go
so female Thor is actually Jane Foster
who we find out is suffering from breast
cancer she's slowly dying and refuses
Asgardian treatment but you kind of get
the idea that because she is so fearless
she becomes worthy of Mjolnir so she's
able to pick it up so that's how she
becomes female Thor but you know the
funny twist is is that Odin is super
pissed off about this he's like this is
my son's hammer you're an outside like
he's really pissed that a human can pick
up Mjolnir but Thor can't but because of
what Nick Fury whispered to Thor and
Odin
they're both unworthy so everyone's just
like what the hell did he whisper to
them to make them so unworthy in the
comic book writer Jason Aaron who's
responsible for all but just said that
he will reveal it eventually but I'll be
interested to see if he has another
unworthy type moment during this movie
but one of the reasons in movies why
they don't chop people's arms off more
often is because a lot of times like in
order to make his guru metal arm from
the comics look really awesome on screen
they'd have to use a lot of CG that gets
really expensive if Thor's going to be
in a lot of scenes so what might be
happening here is if like he has
something on his arm here it's just
armor that he wears while he's in the
gladiator arena and that's only
temporary it's not like a complete
replacement for his arm like we know
that Hulk wears his armor from Planet
Hulk in Thor Ragnarok they showed that
off at Comic Con so it makes sense that
Thor would be wearing some kind of armor
if he's fighting in the gladiator arena
too so that's probably what this is but
let me know in the comments do you think
that they are going full unworthy Thor
and they're going to give him a new
roommate alarm in this movie but for
those of you asking about this picture
here this is the comic book that's
coming up even if you don't read Thor
comics this hammer here is actually the
ultimate Thor's hammer that's left after
the big secret Wars event that happened
last summer so if you didn't read Secret
Wars basically like everybody in the
Marvel Universe was crammed onto a
single planet there were a bunch of
Thor's from a bunch of different
universes so this hammer is just left
over from that that the main universe
Thor is now going to try and pick up
it's like the main version of Thor in
the comics who is unworthy so one of the
advantages
the course of the multiverse is that
there's an infinite number of mjolnir's
so if he becomes worthy again that means
that he and Jane Foster female Thor can
both wield a Mjolnir and be a fully
powered version of Thor so you have like
to Thor's in the Marvel Universe but
just a tile of this - Avengers infinity
war on the movies and the next like the
fourth Avengers film which is currently
untitled I think what they're doing is
just getting people used to the idea of
different Avengers so that when they get
to the fourth Avengers movie they can do
all-new all-different Avengers in the
movies like you have a bunch of
different Avengers joining the team a
bunch of classic Avengers getting cycled
out so don't be surprised if you see
like spider-man officially join the
Avengers and like be in all the Avengers
in a really big way along with other
characters like Captain Marvel but
that's like a long ways up we're talking
like way after infinity war but that's
another good question let me know in the
comments how different do you think the
Avengers team is going to be in the
fourth Avengers film like do you think
that they're going to cycle a bunch of
people and find creative ways for some
of the older Avengers to not show up
quite as much but just because I forgot
to do it in my earlier Marvel videos
this week there is a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video they'll be much more Marvel and DC
this week I just posted my Suicide Squad
review so I'll put a link in the
description for that so lots of
comic-book stuff happening this week
well you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my
non-spoilery Suicide Squad review you
can click here for all my marvel
trailers from Comic Con thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight